[Music]
this week we've got garbage heroes Oh TV
thievery
oh and seeing-eye puppy what garbage
hero sure it's like the tar hero but
then you pretend like you're the garbage
man and you throw it like a good job
growing up maybe to like come into the
neighborhood like hanging on the side
like a rundown guy was like that's that
was a good job you fun yeah that doesn't
look pretty fun hella money they get
paid while you paint it on garbage
people I'm not I just never looked at a
garbage man and well I want to be him
that's my job it's a boy thing yeah
sometimes didn't you have to go out the
machine just goes out and then takes the
trash and now say I'm talking to my back
feels like the trash boom when they like
that is the guy thing I think they still
do that gloves and stuff there for those
like those big onesies yeah in New York
this was in New York okay so picture
like New York aliens you like I was
gonna say dirty ass New York but they're
really mean you know there's a lot of
garbage in New York because there's a
lot of people and they just throw it on
the street they just leave their trash
on the sidewalk yeah dirty ass New
Yorkers so this guy his name is April
home Levitt his wallet fell into a
shopping bag and then he just threw the
shopping bag away he didn't think about
it [ __ ] worst nightmare so type of
thing to do yeah exactly
David so dropped his wallet literally
got that twice so do you have a like
device in your wallet like tile if you
lose I do now like it because if I had
that it makes me feel like I'm useless
so I just take the risk just to prove to
yourself you don't forget what I've done
it twice I've done it twice but I got
back twice yeah so I you got it bad
twice maybe it made me hope in the world
Wow someone returned it to you yes they
saw the tracking device actually turned
it in before I got the tracking device
Wow I dropped my I dropped this wallet
and it was like you need to get rid of
that wall
that's whoa yeah I had a friggin like
black-eyed peas thing I ain't Hollywood
I just hit a black guy's house in the
gutter and some guy I don't know me but
now it was social media they can wake up
your name they can see your Instagram or
something yeah he's like oh [ __ ] Bristol
Farms with his son
Armenian duties like I just wanna show
my son this is the right thing these are
maybe in the wallet so I get a male heir
card in there to make me everything back
I was like did he give it back to you
then curse you out after because he's
Armenian not took a picture of my
history check my answer grabbed me and
his son like hey man I was trying to
give him money and he wouldn't take you
at economic oh that's awesome breaking
stereotypes everyday shout out shout out
well so this guy threw it in the garbage
she wasn't as lucky but he knew that he
was a type of guy to forget things so he
installed that security device in there
the next morning so he was watching like
a parade or something it was some big
event in New York and he threw it in a
random trash can and the next morning
he's like oh [ __ ] my wallet was in there
so he calls like the the garbage company
and they actually held the truck that
had his wallet in it until Monday
yeah there's dude I would never even
think about calling to do this yeah
maybe like on this is God I'm like it's
gone forever
device in his wallet he did he had to
follow mark so you went to the dump in
New York is that Newark cuz that's where
the truck so he GPS to his [ __ ]
wallet
well he tried to but it didn't even work
because it was so covered in piles and
piles in the wallet I even know about
these things until I read this article
maybe I should get that didn't work for
him oh because it was covered under
piles and piles of garbage how did he
know it was in that garbage truck
because I guess they know like the route
what yeah exactly what trucks picked up
what trash cans and so since he couldn't
find it because it wasn't tracking it a
sanitation worker dumped out 20 to 30
individual garbage bags graduate
for this dude to sift through until he
finally dug out his wallet which
contained $68 in cash he gave to the man
yeah no no yeah he had 16 bucks some
credit cards and his toddler's passport
card
oh we were literally in a pile of refuse
and God lifted us up I felt so excited I
couldn't believe it
and he desperately needed these credit
cards because he was about to go on a
trip to Poland the next week okay and so
he was expressing how worth was worth it
yeah yeah amazing company exactly he
says that now after this experience he
thinks differently about the people who
pick up the track well what did you
think about [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] come
back you $68 holding [ __ ] looking damn
he's look they probably make more money
than his ass he's like anything it was
former [ __ ] inmates trash differently
about them and he's very grateful and
he's like they love this guy
meters everyone was so kind like God
will love the garbageman his well what
the Poland
yeah yeah and I guess he tweeted at them
and the garbage company was like you got
it yeah what the [ __ ] they're like you
got it what did he think of them bees
were like what yeah I didn't even know
they had a stereotype oh it was like you
and he went to a Neiman Marcus after he
sprayed his whole body in Cologne he's
like it's not so bad
but they're really nice people I didn't
know does he think that they're homeless
people that are collecting the dirt and
shoes he from is he from here or is he
from Poland
no he's from here he's a real estate
broker in [ __ ] I was like maybe lost
in translation
yeah no sir I mean it could be lost in
translation in the article too like they
just don't make him sound very good
people also don't know how much garbage
guys make yeah
Union guys like it's a government job
yeah well I think they help me they they
outsourced to private companies but
they're like a lot of the Union guys
make like a
like 70 or 80 G's a year and they went
above and beyond here like they didn't
have yeah and the [ __ ] is I lost my
wallet I'm like why are you calling me
good luck idiot I know so he threw it in
a baguette he threw it in the garbage
yeah like and he knows he's forgetful
cuz he does [ __ ] like this all the time
one in the back I do that sometimes
throw my keys in the trashcan before I
put my sunglass or whatever you just
couldn't con condense what is it called
convinced yeah just like your grocery
bags like like you just have your cell
phone and then you have your keys and
then your wallet right girl like look at
these [ __ ] pockets like I barely have
any pockets face that's not real pocket
yeah it's not a real pocket laptop in
the frigerator once shut up I'm scared
oh I did leave my phone in there I had
to call it in the fridge thing before we
can find your wallet and your wallet
your phone you press it in it rings your
phone uh what about your phones on
silent does it still because GPS is it
yes I magic that's why I got a fanny
pack
oh I just got away know what I love it
Oh Fanny my fanny pack you know a tiny
fanny pack yeah last one right yeah no
but tiny wallet I could put my shirt
over it and it just looks like I'm fat
the next one is the dude kept the TV
that was mailed to him by accident what
a thief he ordered a 74 inch TV they
delivered an 86 inch TV and usually no
one's gonna say anything no one's saying
anything yes thank you measure yeah I
installed it we were going to that
virtual reality place oh yeah so we were
at the gas station I was pumping gas
this guy pulls up on us oh yeah he was
like hey you guys want a free TV free
yeah right here I've tried to get rid of
it extra once and I'm like no he said I
it drives off of my back [ __ ] weird
what you just had a bunch of TV I bought
speakers from that dude one time how
would you pay I got a good deal a while
ago I got good that one is really
is like some other speakers I had but it
was a good sales pitch hey you had to do
what you had to do do I do the Goss
scene first
what if he was just trying to move and
he had nowhere to place it so he was
just no he was wearing a uniform like in
his car was like like it was like like
Best Buy and yeah like a Best Buy coward
it took it weird oh but that's legit
thought it wasn't best buy it it just
matched but it was like what if they had
like a tracking device and a camera in
it that you don't watch you at your
spell too weird anomaly it did feel
thank you I would have taken all how I
looked at him I know what I lost them in
the garbage can sir I did look in the
backseat I was like nice we're not very
particular about my TVs anywhere yes so
the police came in and they found it
mounted on his wall already why would
the police come in okay so the police
came in why because the shipping company
called the police on him so he says he
goes in a quote I looked into all the
laws and said you know it's a scratch
ticket sometimes you win sometimes you
lose he said adding that Amazon said I
had nothing to worry about
I made no wrong decisions at that point
but the shipping company says no
actually we tried to call this
[ __ ] like so many times he never
answered we left multiple messages wish
it yeah and if they coming after you
guys yeah but you don't know if it's a
random number if it's a telemarketer you
just you just cancel that call right or
they could leave a message who does that
he just said like the message nobody I
fell like once every two months
yeah but if they sent to the wrong
that's on them they got big yeah no
that's not cool I know it's not cool but
if you just lost your wallet twice and
it gave me a chill the Arminian is so
mad at you right now I was like you're
right tell your son you right you're
gonna give it that's different if they
ask you for you gotta give it back if
you got upgraded it's like surprise
surprise I'm lucky so he he's pissed
because like he's like who wouldn't you
know keep you know I would not I believe
in [ __ ] karma and [ __ ] bad Jews
you just like I like you what you go to
get it out you order a cheeseburger
animal-style they give you a
double-double I don't want it have you
ever gotten a McDonald's before and you
got a six-piece nugget and they gave you
eight are you gonna go back
you got ace a medium french fry day and
it gave you a large you go back and get
the medium one uh medium french fries
and give me a large know what if they're
like when the police came I'm a [ __ ]
like all of you guys
he went deeper because I actually would
be like I measured it and I want it
smaller for this wall take the bigger
one he should have gone that direction
but so he's making it hard for me if the
cops came to my house I would literally
just put on dark sunglasses on a long
standard let's do this and it would even
make sense well how are you watching the
TV why would it not listen to the team
yeah I listen to the sighs oh you mean
the sound box yes
so yeah the police the police like tried
to question him first and he was like
skirting their answers cuz he's like do
I need an attorney and they're like no
we're just asking questions so that's
why he's pissed that he got arrested
because he's like they said I didn't
need an attorney they lied that's what
cops do oh my god this guy's stupid and
stupid
basically the police were like do you
have a TVs like I don't recall it and
then the police were like well he
refused to cooperate with us so we
arrested him and Abby deserves yeah he's
like Charles knee over $1,200 by false
pretense and misleading a police offers
these cops had nothing better to do the
guy's probably a jerk no he says if I
knew I was gonna be arrested I would
have paid for the larger TV or
returndate why was it why was the
shipping company doing this was a
third-party shipping company you know
cuz amber were getting in trouble yeah
and then so they're like Amazon's that
yeah from Amazon mm-hmm we got good
stuff on Amazon no grave I just always
thinks like a robot is just robots on
Amazon I always you know they would make
a mistake like that
well the Shi the shipping company is a
third party so maybe it was Amazon
robots being like deliver this TV in the
shipping I miss all customer service is
really good really good yeah cuz I've
had stuff that got lost in the mail and
they just refunded everything back and
they said 77 you meet you on them
something like oh [ __ ] yeah they're like
if you want to keep it it's on us yeah
that's what I got that's why I got so I
got extra shoes and I was like okay I'll
keep it yeah that's happened before -
because I'll order some [ __ ] and they
they just let me keep some because it
came three weeks later and I just kept
both of them I was like yeah cuz it was
supposed to come during a certain week
and it didn't so I emailed Domino's like
where's it at homie and like we're
sending you another one and the other
ones on its way but if you get it go
ahead and keep it yeah that wasn't the
most like going from a boss whatever
[ __ ] and they're okay with this yeah he
says that Amazon told them that he had
nothing to worry about so he thought he
was fine that's what he says but I think
I guess his TV got switched with another
person's TV or something and they're
saying that he signed for the incorrect
delivery but he's like no I just signed
for whatever delivery I believe that
because I just do that they just give me
a paper and just sign it mm-hmm damn he
got and the thing is he didn't like I
mean yeah he got the upgrade and got
busted but here we paid for a TV yeah I
think it was when he was skirty
he's probably a German there's nobody we
know that would get into a situation
like this that would end up going to
jail for something if they pay for they
got a little extra ice probably other
cops have a lip yeah yeah he's probably
a douche Benny yeah the police of the
great because I mean what he could have
done is like hey I like the 86 inch let
me pay the difference yeah exactly he
could have done that and he's like wool
they told me that I wasn't in trouble if
I knew I was in trouble I would have
paid the difference okay
the last story is really really cute are
you ready you'll like this okay this
couple had on national puppy day they
had it was an eleven year old Golden
Retriever Charlie and he was suffering
from severe glaucoma and one of his eyes
so the owners were forced to have the
doctors remove his left eye
a year later that's exaggerated here to
remove this other eye
so this dog why does it get cute where
did it get you this dog he's fine he's
it's painless he's having a good time
but he just blocked and now he's blind
okay listen
a year later national puppy day okay
they got him his own seeing-eye dog Oh
seeing-eye dog yeah so he's a slaver
yeah and like basically so it's a it's a
four month old puppy maverick and an
holy train and he's training right now
to be a seeing-eye dog for a dog yeah
for its wild you can also be a service
animal to humans to like later on you
can be a service animal so he network
does he like tug on he's like yeah
actually let me just show you this is
both of them use like a pillow because
he's blind that's why you can't tell he
uses them as a pillow and they played
together
maverick shows him like where to go and
then Charlie like teaches maverick
manners because he's a puppy dog so they
they just totally teach you dog in the
whole food chain and animal kingdom dogs
really stepped out of it they really
were like yeah we ain't buck with the
rest of the animals in the dog yeah
they're not there we're just over here
some subhuman category yeah yeah like
humans on top of it no like and we're
just like one a yeah wasn't tight that
what Tyson was blind in both eyes right
Omaha
well he had cloudy eyes yeah but wasn't
a blind but there's moments of dementia
yeah scary they took the eyeballs of his
eyes were bad as [ __ ] up why would
they take the eyeballs out of the dog
just let the dog be eyes are bad we
talked about they look cloudy yeah but
that's every older dog because I look
like dishwater what does it look like
you just look at the closet [ __ ] it's
all blurry don't worry it's all blurry
and like my dog got it too like it
almost turns white yeah humans get that
[ __ ] right yeah for sure yeah
puppy maverick helps him with with
walking with playing and with eating and
I started an Instagram account of for
for the puppies and it immediately their
photos kind of went viral and they got
like 67 thousand followers right mom you
want to if you want to follow them
Charlie Charlie and math yeah like right
over that dog want to do that so you
working so young he is he even happy or
is Ian slave easy like walking over this
day I gotta walk around this damn ass
old dog on time that's true I'm hella
young I just gonna be like a puppy and
run around Bebe's like fun and chase
Lilly chugging labor
yes child labor I agree I'm with you
petty right a dog in a B they're friends
we don't know their forest friends but
they're okay how is your grandmother all
day every day
this is locked around and [ __ ] all day
dogs are more athletic than human my
blonde ass grandma guy hitter
not even like in your grandma would be
just some random old lady good night my
grandma it's just some guy down the
block and ground just sleeping on you
familiar but you don't even know any
different because this is like you were
born into it boy your stink dog slavery
that's your life is it aren't all dogs
slaves if you think about it did they
choose to be in your home yes did they
choose to get that frisbee I don't want
to be in the streets
my dog [ __ ] never gets the frisbee
for me I throw something in the dogs
like [ __ ] you can't get that spoil your
dogs that's why they don't like to play
fetch hot nah they don't give a [ __ ] my
cat used to play fetch when he was a kid
and then as he got older he's like wait
why am i returning this so now he goes
and chases it he goes I found it not
starting to like cats yeah yeah we gonna
get a kitty no I'm just just crazy
allergic I'm alert me to buy her tea you
get used to it so I'm thinking that
right so I heard that [ __ ] too so I'm so
so I keep I'm not even kidding you but
like like you know people say like if
you stay around it won't be as bad right
[ __ ] because I woke up with that cat
on my face [ __ ] two [ __ ] rise
again dude oh well it's shut dude that
cat literally sues cat one face it's my
managers girlfriends Kay so he has to
now but there's one of them's like a dog
so it likes to be by you sleeping at
your managers girlfriend's house no
because I have my podcast at there at
the condo so they live together so like
but then I really live at that townhouse
so they took it over but I left my
podcast there so cuz it hold it I'm
hella logic ass too but then I was
dating this one girl and I was super in
love with her and then somehow the cat
was cool huh why she would sleep in the
bed we love took away that yeah like
something like if you don't affect you
he loves you back you go in a girl's
house and you're allergic to cats and
you try to get some and you see the cat
and then you your timer goes off your
head like yeah make some happen next for
you I got like 40 minutes maybe this
[ __ ] ain't happenin 40 minutes I gotta
get the hell out of this house that [ __ ]
was a deal-breaker for me I'm like oh
she's got a cat is a deal-breaker look
like that but I got used to one cat
which makes me Maggie love conquers all
she said she got nasty she's yeah oh my
god nasty dog sheets think cat sheets
cats are
clean there's some cats that are
hypoallergenic I want that one that
looks like a ball sack lissa called the
ball
oh this the hairless well you're right
there's some cats always there's a rag
doll when they breed them
there's teacup kitties and they get no
more than six pounds and they're bred
for personality and to be hyper
allergenic any one of those
[ __ ] did a teacup kitty I can
mess with a cat early to Grandma that's
like kinda hard to bring us off this
infection it's just this cats a little
too needy so it just because I wanted it
to like me a lot and now it likes me too
much too much so every time I come into
the house it's waiting yeah cats are
like boyfriends and girlfriends dogs I
feel like I like your kids and then cats
are like your partner they say cats are
like like a roommate and like a dog like
a child like they're independent but if
they love you their life where the [ __ ]
were you you get like you a lot but I
want a cat that can also go outside and
can live in the streets I know when you
get home and then they do this thing the
cat's just in the apartment of the house
all day that's our whole world yeah
that's the house is messed up but the
cat that can go outside and hunt and do
its own damn thing all my characters
start shooting dices that's a catch you
want a cat that's like a living life a
neighborhood cat is what you want
because then all his hair is not in the
apartment cause he's actually Roger he's
gonna bring pinworms this your house
maybe unless nasty [ __ ] maybe give my
cat crickets and cockroach no they would
play with you yeah it's like I want a
[ __ ] food man I just want a canned
food like all the other K no it's a
neighborhood cat it wasn't really my cat
but I think she'd like to think it was
your cat you're like earn it
[Music]
[Music]